well it's time now to turn to our press
previewer first look at what is on
tomorrow's historic front pages as they
pay their tributes to her majesty the
queen
well joining us sir
to have us through it all are the
journalists can broadcaster Jenny
cleeman and the author and former Royal
photographer Ian Lloyd you're very
welcome thanks for joining me well let's
uh see then how some of the papers are
covering this simply momentous story
momentous doesn't even do it justice and
there we have the mirror quite simply
says thank you
The Daily Star praises the Queen's
Legacy saying you did your duty man
and the Metro carries this simple but
simply beautiful image of her majesty
and the telegraph quotes the Queen's own
words
grief is the price we pay for love
and the times focuses on comments by now
King Charles III who's described his
mother's passing as the greatest sadness
for his family
black and white photograph the guardian
has chosen this elegant image of her
majesty
and the sun we love you ma'am is how the
sun has thanked the queen for those 70
years of service
and yes the even the financial times of
course puts its usual coverage of
Economics to one side in deference to
her majesty the queen a beaming Queen
Elizabeth II there well as I say we're
joined tonight by Jenny kleeman and Ian
Lloyd and uh let's take in some of those
front pages some quite simple but
wonderful images and let's start with
the time Zinda Jenny I suppose the only
real difference between the papers is
whether they have gone for the queen as
she was plenty of them going for those
some of those coronation pictures or as
most of us I suppose are going to
remember her now the the grandma to the
nation
very much so she looks very
grandmotherly doesn't she in this
picture I mean how do you sum up this
end of an era in one front page we know
that the papers plan these sorts of
things in advance but it it is so
difficult she has presided over so much
change and I think there are lots of
people like me who wouldn't call
themselves big royalists or Royal
Watchers who would never buy a mug or a
tea towel or Hello magazine who are
feeling really sad today and I think
these front pages really speak to that
feeling and I think I mean in in the
copy here on this front page uh it talks
about the Elizabethan era and I think
none of us realized that we were living
in the new Elizabeth new Elizabethan era
until today
um but as as sometimes happens when
people die and you can look back we we
look back on this rain and this
incredible period of history that we've
all lived through and she you know she
was one of the few British institutions
that was constant that commanded
unanimous respect that we all shared and
and the thing that these front pages do
very well is is we're mourning two
things today we're mourning a person a
lifetime of dignified service and we're
also mourning the end of her her Reign
and era of of britishness when at a time
when it feels like everything is
Shifting so much
um she being something that was constant
something uh that we all shared so much
and I think you know these front pages
they all show how much she embodied
britishness and there are so many
different reasons that people feel
patriotic it could be the Pomp and
ceremony the history it could be the
Empire or it could be uh decency and
dignity and honor that we're meant to
have as British people have a reputation
for and she embodied all of that so so
these front pages very cleverly uh
reflect both her as a as a as a head of
state and her as a remarkable person who
who sacrificed so much much to to play
that role so well
that is such a very good point it is of
course about her about her majesty about
the family but it's also about us Ian
let's take in another front page
um as we said they're all of course
pictures of her majesty let's take in
the the mirror a different image of
course and and just tell me your
thoughts and of course we're looking and
analyzing and remembering the queen is I
suppose amateurs when it comes to
photography you're a professional you've
I mean you've taken so so many pictures
like this
well I'd like to have taken one's in
this situation this is by Lord
Litchfield who is a cousin of the queens
and that was for the golden jubilee of
2002 uh what's quite striking is just
the words thank you because we didn't
always thank the queen and when we took
her for granted the only time we really
did think to thank it was at the Jubilee
and marvelously she lived
to be able to participate in the 70th
Jubilee the Platinum one and that was
always an occasion when um you could
thank her and I do remember that people
burst into the national anthem and sang
it with Vigor while she was on the
balcony um I was there and it was an
incredibly moving moment this tiny
little figure that had made it we didn't
think she'd make it we were told she's
you know in doubt but she did make it
from Windsor and um that was one of the
enduring images of the rain I think and
as I say it was an opportunities to
thank her which we didn't always do
that again is such a great point in uh
yes we we didn't thank her very much but
the reality is she didn't expect it
was all about Duty it was all about
service wasn't it let's uh take in
another of these front pages we've got
the the telegraph now and uh Jenny let's
just
soak up that image and this then what
what a quotation this is grief is the
price we pay for love I mean how true
and how simple that is
and I think really well chosen given how
the reaction of people today I think a
lot of people are just really surprised
they've you know I've been in touch with
lots of people who've said that they
have cried and they didn't expect to cry
uh today and you know she's a 96 year
old woman it's not uh it's not a total
shock that this this would happen uh but
I think we are we are grieving as a
nation here we are celebrating her life
but also uh grieving and you know
we say that you know we we didn't get to
thank her but I am glad that um she she
got to see the Jubilee this year and she
got to see how profoundly she was loved
and and remained loved uh right till the
end uh and she was you know serving the
country right to the end even when she
was frail it is remarkable to think of
those images that we saw 48 hours ago on
Monday when she was you know seeing in a
new uh wine Minister she will always be
remembered as somebody who is profoundly
loved and who dedicated her life to
service
and did a Judy right up to the very end
yes you're right that uh a changeover of
prime ministers it seems such a very
long time ago now talk about a very long
time we've been looking at images on the
front of the papers of Contemporary
Images more or less of a Majesty the
queen let's take in another one now
because many of them have gone way way
back they've gone back to the coronation
let's have a look I think we've got next
there the star
and
there we go
The Daily Star and uh there we are in
all the regalia way back
1953 the coronation wasn't it of course
1952 when she she came to the throne and
Ian what different times they were you
know we hear about people it boosted
sales of black and white televisions
people huddling around a few that they
were in a street not many people even
had telephones or indeed inside toilets
etc etc what an era she has spanned
absolutely I mean when she came to the
throne in 1952 Joseph Stalin was still
leading the Soviet Union Chiang Kai-shek
in in China Harry S Truman in in America
and of course Winston Churchill was her
first prime minister who entered
parliament in the reign of Queen
Victoria so it's it was an amazing uh
breadth of history that she's lived
through but one thing looking at this is
I think a younger generation when they
look at these photographs will not have
realized just how glamorous the queen
was I mean Prince Philip once said the
adulation you couldn't believe it in the
early days and he said we made a cons a
conscious decision not to appeal to the
gallery not to play the part of the
celebrities but just to get on with the
job which is what she always did but you
just look at that and see what a
beautiful young woman she was 25 when
she came to the throne the same age as
Queen Elizabeth the First and here she's
27 at the coronation and a very
glamorous figure
foreign
I think we're out of time for this hour
at Jenny Clement and Ian Lloyd so we
just want to end this paper review let's
just take in the the Metro because it's
another of those striking images from
the the coronation years and that's such
a lovely point you make Ian let's just
have a look at I think it's coming up
soon the the Metro please
uh no we're not going to see that
because it was such a such a lovely
image there we are of uh the young Queen
Elizabeth in her finery
just after she'd acceded to the throne
herself on the death of her father
George VI such a shock to her back then
as it is a shock to us all now